welcome back to lockdown math where we
try to answer some of the
important questions in life some of the
deeper things that
are relevant push your life forward like
for example
what if you have a bank that offers you
an interest rate of the square root of
negative one
a negative not even a negative interest
rate we thought that was weird enough
an imaginary interest rate should you
take it
now i almost guarantee however
interesting you think this question is
it's going to be more interesting than
that i think
there's going to be some people who find
it totally nonsensical right which
is reasonable what on earth would it
mean for your money to grow by the
square root of negative one
and i think there's also some people who
think they know where this lesson is
going
um but wherever you sit i almost
guarantee this is going to be more
interesting than you think
um and to start things off let me bring
back our poll that we were doing
you know during the warm-up animations
and i just want to get a sense for
what your instinct is on this apparently
nonsensical question
okay so obviously there's no right or
wrong answer here it's something that
we're going to answer by the end
but i'm genuinely curious what you
viewing right now
think if a bank offers you an annual
interest rate
of the square root of negative one do
you take it
so if you want to participate um either
in this poll or any of the live quizzing
that we do throughout
obviously 3b1b.co live is where you can
go
link in the description as well and
while you're answering this
i just want to mention that even if this
is kind of a nonsensical question for
money
one of the things i'd like to show by
the end is that thinking through the
details of this question
is shockingly relevant to physics okay
and to understanding
simple harmonic motion so even if it
feels like nonsense if you're willing to
engage with the
weird storyline for a bit there is a
satisfying real world endpoint for that
the other thing i want to mention is a
brief plug for a video by mathologer
if you guys don't know mathologer you're
certainly in for a treat
but he did this one called e to the pie
i for dummies
and in general the channel is just full
of gems but this video in particular
um contains a lot of the things that i
want to talk about today
and it's just so beautifully done it's
extremely well presented
extremely approachable burkard who
presents it is
extremely lovable so could not recommend
that and other things highly enough
good thing to watch maybe right after
this or even if you're watching this in
the future
you know to watch right before this um
so looking back at our poll
fascinating we've got a very even split
between the yeses and the nos
i wouldn't have guessed that actually
and i'm curious if by the end of this uh
once we see what the implications would
be
how many of you would stand by your
answers so let me just
let me just see what this distribution
is because i am curious to know
all right so it looks like seven
seventeen hundred of you uh said yes you
would take the imaginary interest rate
um and then uh 1645 of you said no
all right we'll see if you stand by that
by the end and which way really
understand the implications
of imaginary interest now before that
let's ask a question that um is a little
bit more real world
because i think we should spend the
first i don't know half hour of the
lesson or so
on actual normal compound interest right
the kind of interest that we would all
usually think of make sure we can build
up some of the math of that
and then once we have the math of that
see how we can tweak it to answer our
well frankly silly question okay so it
was our first
um i don't even want to call it a real
question it's still meant as an opinion
poll
uh don't necessarily think you have to
do the computation what i want to gauge
is what your gut reaction to this
question is
okay so there is a correct answer but
just answer what you what you think it
might be
so the question asks two banks offer
different interest rates on your savings
bank a will increase your savings by 12
every year okay pretty good bank bank b
will increase your savings by one
percent every month
again i wish my bank worked like this um
with each of these banks you set up an
account with
a hundred dollars and after one year
which of the following is true
so you have more money with bank a by
more than a dollar
so the difference between what you have
in a and b is greater than a dollar
you have more money in bank a but by
less than a dollar
you have the same amount in each more in
bank b
but by less than a dollar or more in
bank b by more than a dollar
okay so it seems like we have pretty
strong consents
no i don't know if i would call that
strong consensus actually there's a
clear winner
um but there's definitely a lot of
contention
behind it and in general by the way
while uh
while these answers are rolling in i'll
sometimes be pulling up questions from
the audience which you can ask via
twitter
um so the link is in the description for
you know where you can go to ask these
sorts of questions
and it looks like uh someone with the
profile of yoda
asks even though mathematical facts are
derived through logical proofs
somehow we stumble upon beauty beautiful
connections between seemingly unrelated
areas
a great example is euler's identity do
you think that such serendipity
renders math a quintessential beauty
what a poetically written tweet
which seems pretty fitting for someone
uh with a profile of
yoda in there i mean it's a subjective
question personally i do think the most
beautiful things are the ones that have
unexpected connections uh and i don't
know if that's like a natural thing that
humans just love to see
things that seemed unrelated come
together humor seems to have this root
like a really good joke
kind of takes you by surprise but when
it's when there's some kind of logical
connection it's not just surprise for
its own sake
and as the lesson goes on if you have
questions relevant you know to what
we're talking about
ask them there and we'll pull them up on
screen so
like i said there's technically a right
answer to this question but i don't
really want it to be treated as right or
wrong
the reason i'm asking this one is to get
kind of an opinion poll to know where
people are starting
so i'm going to go ahead and lock in the
answers and see where people are
interesting this might be the first time
in lockdown math history
that the plurality has not gotten what
turns out to be the correct answer
so most of you said you would have more
money with bank b
and it would be by more than a dollar
the second
most common answer was to say you'd have
more money with bank b by less than a
dollar
um which turns out to be correct we're
going to walk through that in a moment
after that more with bank a and
i think the ones that i most um
empathize with
if i look back at like what maybe an uh
an initial response to questions like
this would be if you haven't thought
about interest
is everyone who said c you know it's not
obvious that 12
over a year is gonna be any different
than one percent per month
like well one percent per month that
should add up to 12 over the year
um and i think it's it's worth just
thinking through exactly why that's not
the case
so how do we think about this kind of
problem i've gone ahead and pulled up a
desmos graph for us to play around with
so we'll
get rid of berkard's beautiful face and
we'll head on over to desmos
and the way i have things configured
it's going to be showing us the graph
of what happens to your money in this
case in bank a so over the first
year at any point that you check in it's
just got that hundred dollars
and it's not until the end of the year
that it jumps up to a hundred and twelve
dollars
and the way you might think about that
is by saying okay let's take our hundred
dollars at the end of the year
we had twelve percent of that hundred
dollars and sensibly enough you get 112.
and a nice way to think about this which
seems simple and it seems kind of
innocuous but this turns out to be
um i don't know a powerful idea we'll
talk about more why i
might want to emphasize that this is
more of a significant move than you
might think
the fact that the rate of change is
proportional to the thing that's
changing
means we can factor out this 100 and we
can just say
oh that step that we take we're
multiplying it by a constant
in this case that constant would be 1.12
so as you go from this step to the
second year at the end of that second
year
your account balance doesn't jump by
just 12 because it's also earning
interest on the 12
extra dollars that you got that last
year so it jumps up to 125.
it's a multiplicative amount and this
becomes particularly
noticeable as we zoom out and see what
would happen over the course of many
years
with such a fantastic interest rate in
your bank
it's not just growing like a straight
line it grows with this exponential
curve
and in fact if you look at 10 years in
it looks like the y coordinate of that
is around 310. so you let your money sit
in that savings account
with 12 interest for 10 years and you'd
end up with
three times as much money pretty
interesting
so now when we start thinking about
having the interest accrue
not just at the end of the year but at
various chunks on the way in
let me just let me just ask you another
question i think this is a fun way to
start things off is rather than having
me go through the logic have
you guys think through the details so
before we jump to the case of doing
a step every month let's just say there
was two steps halfway through the year
so what does the question ask us says a
bank offers to increase the money in
your savings account
by six percent at the end of every six
months
which of the following represents how
much money will be in your account
if you put in a hundred dollars and then
you wait for one year
so there's two different six-month
periods that have passed
which of the following expressions shows
how much you're going to have
alright so i'm going to give you a
moment to think through the details of
this
give you a little pause and ponder music
maybe
okay as always i'm probably going to
grade this faster than
is a reasonable amount of time for
someone who really wants to
think through the details of things so
never feel like you're being rushed
sometimes it's just that i want to move
forward with the lesson and it seems
like answers are rolling in a little bit
more slowly now
so i'm going to go ahead and lock this
in but as always feel free to pause and
just think things through more yourself
if you want
we're going to explain it in a moment so
the correct expression which
it looks like 3 000 of you got is that
it should be a hundred dollars
times one plus 0.6 squared
all right now let's think through why
that might be the case so if we head
back over to
our desmos expression that we were
working with
if instead of increasing by 12 we're
saying increase by 6 percent
when you factor it out it looks like
multiplying by
1.06 okay and then there's two ways you
can think about this if you're already
comfortable with the idea that
increasing by six percent is multiplying
by this constant
you say oh we just square that right and
if you want to think through uh the
details for why that's true if that's
not something you're entirely
comfortable with
you can say let's repeat the process so
this gets us 106
after that first six month period okay
we've got 106
then we're going to add 6 0.06
times that 106 and that's going to get
us the final amount
but this we can factor because 106 shows
up in two places
because the rate of growth is
proportional to itself it lets us factor
this out
as 106 times 1.06
and then you might realize oh wait i'm
just multiplying by the same constant
that i did before
so i might as well have just gone and
put that constant up there
and because it's the same constant i
might as well have simply written that
as a square so what that means
is if you take these steps of percent
increases many many different times
what it looks like is taking a number
that's a little above one and then
raising it to some kind of power
so to our original question asking about
bank b
which what did it say it's going to be a
one percent increase to your savings
every month
the way you might think about that is by
saying we multiply
by 1.01 okay by one plus that
one percent um and then we do it after
12 months
okay so instead of the instead of the
uh 112 dollars that you would have had
from bank a
whoo-hoo it looks like compounding more
frequently
got us an extra 68 cents in our account
so
wonderful right in our graph if we
wanted to see what that would look like
again there's some machinery under here
that i'll i'll show in a moment
but if i just crank up this number n to
12
that's basically asking how many times
per year
do i compound this interest do i make a
little step
increase based on what the annual
interest rate is so if the annual
interest rate was 12 percent
and you're making steps each 1 twelfth
of a month of a munch
of a month that means you increase by
one percent each one of those
so what it looks like is a step function
that's a lot more fine
okay and we can see how at the end of uh
the one year
the y coordinate of our graph is that
112 dollars with the extra 68 cents
not quite a dollar more but it is more
and
again as we zoom out you can see that it
fits this nice
exponential curve the power of compound
growth
and if you're curious you know
previously after 10 years
we would have had 310 dollars i think it
was
which we can verify for ourselves if i
take that hundred dollars
times one plus zero point one two to the
tenth
all right this says 310 when we compound
every month instead
and we wait for 120 months it looks like
uh we've squeezed out an extra 20 bucks
so
not bad the important part here though
is the idea that
the frequency with which you compound
actually changes the amount
which is interesting and this is the
original circle of thoughts
that bernoulli was thinking about that
leads to the origins of the constant e
that we all now know and love maybe the
second most famous constant
only next to pi so let's write out some
of what we're doing here but
um with some formulas and then see what
we can start learning with respect to
those formulas
and this is going to help us understand
the bizarre question
of an interest rate of negative not even
negative i keep saying interest rate of
negative one
interest rate of square root of negative
one
nobody should let the fed watch this
video i think
it might introduce some shaky ideas all
right so the way we might think about
this is let's say you start off with
some amount of money
okay and then we're going to let it
accrue some interest over some long
amount of time that i'm going to call t
and the idea is that we're chopping this
amount of time into a bunch of little
pieces
okay and with each one of these steps
we're going to increase our money
there's going to be some kind of
change to m a delta m and each of these
steps
let's say it's got a length of delta t
so maybe delta t
is a 12th of a year or maybe it's one
365th of a year
it depends on how finely we cut it and
just as another
variable to throw down here let's keep
track of how many steps there are along
the way
if we were to count them all up and the
total number would be
the total amount of time divided by the
size of the time steps that we're taking
okay so what interest rates do
is they say that the amount your money
changes is going to equal
that interest rate r and you might think
of r as being something like the
0.12 from our example and then later on
we're going to play around with
making it imaginary but you're going to
multiply it by
the size of your time step okay which
you might think of as being something
like
1 12 if we were compounding monthly
because
simply by compounding monthly it doesn't
mean you get to grow by 12 every month
it means you grow by 1 12 of what the
annual rate was
every month and then what makes compound
growth so powerful
it's also proportional to the amount of
money you had you know if you had 100
that grows by a certain amount if you
had a thousand dollars in there it grows
by 10 times as much
the more you have the more it grows okay
so that
in our example you might think of as
being something like 100
all right so what's the magic of this it
looks innocuous at first
but it means that our money changes by
going to m
plus r delta t
times m and because m shows up in both
of these terms
it lets us factor things out so that m
factors out and we have 1 plus
r delta t
and because this is the same constant
that we're going to multiply for each
one of these little time steps
all you're doing is multiplying by this
constant we can write an expression
for how much money you're going to have
after time t
what it's going to look like is the
amount of money you had to start off
with
at time t equals 0 multiplied by
this expression 1 plus r delta t
and i'll change this in a moment but
i'll keep writing it as r delta t
but we multiply it by itself n times
where n
is the number of steps that we have in
here okay
but there's a lot of different variables
at play here so i want to start
consolidating them
and instead of writing delta t i'm going
to go ahead and express
delta t as the total time divided by n
right it's how we look at the number of
chunks we've cut our period into
and we take the total amount of time and
divide by that
so what our expression will look like is
the amount of money we started with
times 1 plus r
times the total time divided by n so
this
t divided by n is playing the role of
delta t
and we raise that to the nth power
now this is actually a very interesting
expression no pun intended
because we want to know how does the
size of n
influence things right if i crank up n a
lot meaning we're
chopping our interval into very fine
increments and compounding very
frequently
what does that mean for our interest and
uh
you might if you were a pure
mathematician try to abstract away all
the ideas of the money here the specific
interest rate
and just say what we're interested in is
this function
of x that looks like 1
plus 1 over n or maybe i'll say 1 plus
x over n so we want to be able to plug
in some value for
rt and we'll raise that to the power n
but you're not just curious about this
for any particular n
what you want to know is what happens as
you crank up the value of
n and the expression that mathematicians
write for this
we write l i m for limit
and then we write n with an arrow to
infinity saying i want to crank up that
n
and see what happens to this particular
value now it's not obvious i think
what happens to it and playing with my
toy again i just want to do another
uh half opinion poll half real question
about this one
to see what your instinct is okay
so let's say pull up the question here
what happens to the value 100 times
1 plus 0.12 over n to the power
n as the value of n approaches infinity
and in the back of your mind you can
think this isn't just a purely
mathematical
expression it has a very real meaning in
the context of
compound interest what we're basically
saying is if you have that 12
interest rate and you want to wait one
year
but you chop up that year into n
different pieces maybe n is 12
if you compound every month maybe n is
365
if you compound every day or maybe you
want to compound every microsecond or
every picosecond
the question is how much money can you
get at the end of the year simply by
compounding more frequently
if you'll remember when we went from
yearly to monthly that gave us an extra
68 cents
so the question asks basically how high
can this go
and now we have a very wide split which
is wonderful
right i'm gonna give you guys a couple
more moments to think about this
um and i don't want you to calculate it
necessarily the spirit of this question
is to see what your initial thought is
kind of intuitively based on the numbers
so even though technically there's a
right answer to this one so i'll
highlight it green
there's no right or wrong here the
spirit of it is for me to know where
people are
i'll give you give you just a little bit
of time on this
and while i do let's take a question
from the audience considering that
imaginary unit is defined in terms of
operations on the real numbers is there
an analogous definition of
quaternions in terms of operations on
complex numbers
okay so a bit of an advanced question i
don't expect
most people watching the series to
necessarily know what quaternions are
but it's a number system that instead of
including two dimensions like the
complex numbers involves four dimensions
the short answer to the question
i think this is okay to say the short
answer is no right when we get the
complex numbers it's because we
have uh an expression that we don't have
a solution to you wanna know the square
root of negative one
a solution to x squared equals negative
one and by introducing a solution
you extend your number system
quaternions don't come about like that
uh for any polynomial once you have the
complex numbers
you get all the solutions that you could
ever want from that so it's not going to
be there's a problem that you wanted
solved
in the sense of a solution to a
polynomial and you extend it
but where it does come from is the idea
at least historically
is the idea of wanting to describe
motion in three dimensions
and you know complex numbers can
describe things like rotation in two
dimensions
but they don't have enough degrees of
freedom to describe
rotations in three dimensions so in that
sense it was a concrete problem they
couldn't solve
but the construct that you do to add on
top of it doesn't look like
you know a solution to a polynomial kind
of a more advanced question than the
spirit of the lessons necessarily but
obviously i love to
i love to just engage with wherever you
are whoever is watching this
so back to our question i'll go ahead
and grade it and again
uh technically there's a right answer
but don't view this as right or wrong
uh it looks like 1670 of you
correctly noted that this value would
rise above 112 but never above 113
so maybe taking the instincts from the
fact that
when we went from yearly to monthly we
only got 68 cents and saying you can't
get much better than that
next biggest answer interesting was
people who said
it would rise above 114 but stay below
some finite bound
okay so having that instinct that it
would stay finite but
that it was going to get bigger than
anything listed here and i think the
most
uh most uh thought-provoking
answer here is e right the thought that
maybe it should blow up to infinity
i mean we're letting n get as big as we
want uh
it doesn't just have to be down to the
second it could be down to
a plank length it could be down to the
tiniest the biggest number that you
could think of so that our time steps
are as tiny as you can think
it's not at all obvious that this thing
would remain bounded so we can play
around with this a little bit if we want
to
this won't be a proof that it remains
bounded but maybe it can
give us a little bit of an instinct in
that direction if i take
1 plus 0.12 over n
and i raise this to the power n and i
say what happens as we increase
n and 100 that's not big enough i want
to let myself increase it to
some huge number uh you know 100 million
so the value i want you to watch is
sitting right here okay
and remember that represents how much
money you'll have if you compound your
12 interest much more frequently even as
i'm cranking it up around 100 million
this value really stays stable around
1.12 here let's multiply it by the
hundred dollars to make it more
intuitive
around the 112 dollars and you know 74
cents or about 75 cents
it stays really stable around that even
as i'm increasing by a lot
that's not a proof for all we know as
you
venture into the realm of huge huge
numbers
10 to the 300th or grams constant or
whatever big number you want
maybe this thing would slowly crawl up
and eventually get unbounded
but it's an interesting fact that it
doesn't now
in terms of the math behind this we can
do an interesting manipulation
because we have this expression that is
a little funky to think about right
we've got one plus
x over n that you might think of as a
partial interest rate
and we're raising it to the n i can do a
little substitution
and say what if i define the value m
to be n divided by x
okay and the reason for doing that would
be so that i can write that inside
without an x in it so x divided by n
will be the same as 1 divided by
m and now i'll be raising that to the
power
well not n well no the power n but i
want to write it in terms of
m so it would look like m times x
and based on how exponents work i can
think of that just as the quantity
1 plus 1 over m to the power m all
raised to the x
and i'm curious about what happens here
as i crank the value of
m towards infinity and bernoulli was
also interested in what happens
as we crank this value of m up towards
infinity and empirically
what you'll find is if you just play
around with this if we go over and
take out the uh take out the evidence
that we were dealing with a real world
problem with things like that 100
starting value or that uh 12 interest
rate and we just have clean constants
like 1
for each of them it looks like this
value ends up to being around
2.71828 and and
no matter how big you make n it seems to
never really get much different than
that
again not a proof but very suggestive
that this is maybe a fundamental
constant of nature
and so this is the original definition
of e this is the original way that
people were thinking about it
as we pop over here and we say instead
of writing this whole limit expression
we'll use a different color say in
principle
this is going to approach some kind of
constant let's call
this constant e that empirically has a
value around
2.71828
okay and then we can write our whole
thing as e to the
x so for example if we wanted to know
what happens
in our interest example when we started
out with zero dot not zero dollars
started out with m of zero which might
be something like a hundred dollars
um what we do is we just focus on that
rt
term we say we know that as we crank up
n
this is going to approach some special
constant raised to the power
of rt and maybe this we would actually
describe as
uh continuously compounded growth if we
take that time step and we let it
approach zero and this was actually
before
newton and leibniz this was before
calculus existed there was this idea of
trying to take these discrete steps of
increasing and make it approach zero to
get something a little bit more
continuous
so i think that's i think that's quite
cool um
and one thing that you might notice here
is
uh we've got this large expression for
uh basically a function of x that we now
tend to write as e to the x if you
watched the last lecture
you would have remembered that i said
the way things have come about in math
now
whenever we see e to the x we actually
think of it as a shorthand for a certain
polynomial
okay and the polynomial i was calling it
x which
follows convention looks like well 1
plus
x plus x squared over 2 plus x cubed
over 6 and all of the terms
look like x to the k divided by k
factorial
for some whole number k and i said this
is what e to
the x is a shorthand for this is how you
think about it especially when there's
weird inputs
things like an imaginary interest rate
and you might wonder
what on earth does this polynomial have
to do with this
limiting expression and as a super extra
credit
challenge question for those of you who
are really into algebra
and who are very comfortable with
binomial expansion if you
know what those terms mean if you take
this expression
for some large value of n and you expand
it you just expand it and you kind of
simplify your terms
and then you make approximations based
on what's true when n is very large
what you would find is that the
polynomial this expands to
looks a lot like this polynomial here
and in fact
as this value of n gets bigger and
bigger and approaches infinity
this polynomial will get closer and
closer to this one
it's a challenging question so i
wouldn't expect everyone to necessarily
be able to just bang it out but if you
want to it's a very
elucidating exercise and there's also a
lot of delicacy in rigorously proving
the fact
that what this approaches will also
approach this
or that both of them even stay finite
and they don't blow up when you
you know add more and more terms to the
sum or when you crank up n higher and
higher there's a lot of delicacy there
but you can probably get to a point
where there's an intuitive connection
and the reason that in math we tend to
work with this polynomial instead of
that limit
it's basically easier for computations
and easier for theory
but the value of this other expression
is that it ties us back to the idea of
compound interest and the idea of taking
a quantity that changes a little bit
based on its own size you can kind of
readily read this
as saying we're going to multiply by a
certain constant
that's a little above 1 many many times
and if you'll remember the reason we're
doing that
is when the way that you change is
proportional to yourself
that lets you factor things such that
you're just multiplying by something
a little bigger than one and when you do
this
approaching continuity when you do it in
a way where that time step is getting
smaller and smaller
this is when we start writing e to the
power of something
what it's suggesting is that you have
this compound interest expression
but we're letting that n tend towards uh
infinity we're letting the time step go
as small as we want
so with all of that said we can start
having fun
we can start thinking about our original
question of an imaginary interest rate
so how on earth is this going to work
first of all
let's just say from the get go that if
we try plugging in r
to this expression where we're raising a
constant e to a power
it makes no sense um if r is equal to
the square root of negative one you
cannot multiply a constant by itself
the square root of negative one times so
that doesn't make sense but what does
is if we go to this original expression
the origins of e
and try to imagine plugging in something
like i to that
we know how to divide i by n that's fine
we know how to add it to one that's fine
we know how to take a complex number and
multiply it by itself
all of the operations there are quite
fine now let's draw it out to think
about what it would look like
and the other thing i want to emphasize
is i know this seems like utter nonsense
we're talking about imaginary numbers in
the context of interest rates
but in a couple minutes i really do hope
to make this relevant to physics and
hope to make you see that
uh this is not a totally nonsensical
circle of thoughts
all right so if i've got my axes here
where this is going to be my real
this is my real money and this will be
all of my imaginary money
what it means if your interest rate is
i is that the change to the money
looks like i times whatever the time
step
is delta t times whatever the money is
to begin with
now in i believe it was lecture three we
talked all about complex numbers
and one of the fundamental facts was
that when you multiply i
by something it has the effect of a 90
degree rotation
and we talked about this in terms of
looking at the coordinates and realizing
that you just swap the coordinates and
make one negative one
so this connection between a square root
of one property and the very mechanistic
idea of taking a vector
and rotating it 90 degrees now what this
means for us
is that the change to your money
is going to be a little arrow that you
know it's not increasing the money
you're not growing
you're not decreasing the money it's not
a negative interest rate it's moving
somehow perpendicular to where the money
already is
so after a little step in time you end
up uh
with a little bit of imaginary money so
you have what you had originally and you
can play monopoly
and now from that point when you do
another time step
it does the same thing it takes the
vector that you've newly landed on
and it rotates at 90 degrees okay
and then you take a little step based on
that and then again
you take a little step based on that
where at each point you're looking at
what is your
your money number that has some real
part and some imaginary part
you rotate it 90 degrees and you add a
little step on that
and now the question is what happens to
this this is the original question
the bank offers you this interest rate
what's what's it
going to do the correct answer i think
is that you need to ask the bank for
more information because
how frequently you compound it is going
to make a difference so to illustrate
this let's say you compounded it
annually meaning at the end of every
year you take a big step
that's based on this interest rate
multiple so
for every dollar that you have if you
started out uh just putting
your real money into the bank at the end
of the year you would add
i times that amount which is a 90 degree
rotation
of your money again i know this is utter
nonsense
but follow along with me uh one it's fun
and two
it leads to real physics so where does
that get you
well it gets you one dollar plus i
dollars so if you had a hundred dollars
in the bank you end up with 100 real
dollars
and a hundred imaginary dollars but then
after the next year you take another
step where it takes that new money
vector
rotates at 90 degrees and adds that to
where you are
so after two years you come back to your
bank and you say how's my money doing
and they say good news sir there's twice
as much of it say that's fantastic it's
only been two years
and they say bad news it's all imaginary
so
very good for your monopoly game not
great for life logistics
but it gets worse as you wait more time
and you add
another 90 degree rotation of where you
currently are you're going to step
into the negative real territory so at
this point
now you have negative 200 real dollars
but you still have
that uh 200 imaginary uh imaginary
dollars
so good for your monopoly game
devastating now for your actual life
but it gets worse as we take another
step four years later
after you've invested your hard-earned
money you've not even invested you
weren't even putting it at risk it was
just a savings account
and where do you end up for every dollar
you put in you would now have negative
four dollars
so you come to the bank and they say
well you owe us four hundred dollars for
the 100
that you put in four years ago and just
as you're about to get outraged at them
they say sir we encourage you to wait
we really do think this is going to work
out for you if you just let your money
sit
do its work and uh in the long run this
will work out for you
and they're not entirely wrong because
if you keep playing this game
of rotating 90 degrees and then adding
that vector
after a total of 8 years where you're
going to end up
is at 16 times your original amount
not too bad so if you're willing to put
up with a lot of stress
going in changing your monopoly game
changing your real life
and you were willing to just hold for
eight total years
you would have 16 times as much so
that's pretty good i would say
we might call this the um the venture
capitalist
approach where you put in your money you
can't see it for a long time
and most of the time it's completely
imaginary but every now and then you get
a giant multiple at the end
now before you excitedly do this though
let's say that your bank doesn't
compound it annually
right and they say ah actually we
compound your interest continuously
meaning that our time steps are not
delta t of one year
but it's delta t getting smaller and
smaller
well what that means is that each one of
your steps that's perpendicular to where
you are
is really just a tiny little step and
i'm showing with the arrows here what
happens if you wait eight total years
so you take a tiny step that's
perpendicular to where you are another
tiny step that's perpendicular to where
you are
and you keep going but as that time step
gets smaller and smaller
smaller and smaller and smaller to the
point where it's genuinely continuously
compounding interest
what it means is that you're simply
walking around a circle
so if you were writing this out as an
expression you know it might seem
halfway reasonable to look at the fact
that we were using
e to the x as a shorthand for this
limiting value here
and in the case of real numbers that
makes total sense when we plug in a
value for x
um but what it means here is with our
imaginary money
we're writing it as e to the i that was
our interest rate
times the amount of time nonsense if we
think about repeated multiplication
but in the context of compounding
interest all it really means
is that after taking a bunch of steps
that are perpendicular to your current
position
and we do that continuously so those
time steps are just
infinitesimal it has you walking around
a circle
so the bank offers you this do you take
it
well let's think it through what happens
when you put in 100
to your savings account well if you wait
a total of pi
halves years which is the um distance
along a quarter of a circle a little
over a year and a half
you come back into your account and what
do you see well
for each dollar you put in you have an
imaginary dollar
not great uh but you push push through
you know the banker told you that this
will work out in the end so you say okay
i'm gonna wait
i don't i didn't need it for that year
and a half um life wasn't going too
terribly so i'm just going to let my
money still sit in that savings account
for another year and a half or so and
you wait a total of pi
years around 3.14 years you come back
and now it really doesn't look good now
you've got
negative one dollar for each dollar that
you originally put in
and just like before you're infuriated
at the pink not as much as you were
because it hasn't gone out to be
negative four but it's still negative
and that's not fun
and the bank says hold on hold on sir we
think this is actually going to work out
for you in the end
you say okay i've i've seen this work
out for my friends who got 16 times
their money so
i'll just hold and you do you just don't
touch the money in your savings account
you wait another year and a half and you
check and now not only
is it entirely imaginary it's negative
so you can't live your real life and you
also can't even play monopoly well
so 4.7 years is a real low during this
whole experience
but if you're willing to stick it out
and wait a total of 6.28 years
two pie years you come back and for all
of your stress
you're back to where you started you
just have one dollar for every dollar
that you put in originally
so should you accept this interest rate
from your bank depends on how much
emotional turmoil you want but if it's
continuously compounding
certainly not i think is the appropriate
answer
now is this at all useful this is kind
of fun
i think to take an idea that started off
only relevant to real numbers
you know a 12 interest rate um or if you
have negative interest rates you can
think of
how that decays and say well what if we
did something else to it what if each
time step
wasn't in the direction but it was
perpendicular to the direction
and the answer is that this is actually
incredibly relevant to anything that
involves
what's called simple harmonic motion in
physics and so a great example of this
is a spring let's say we wanted to
understand the motion of
a spring so let me pull this up here
i think i have an actual spring sitting
somewhere here if it didn't roll off my
table
oh i i had trouble finding any um
reasonable ones so i tried to just
extract one from my pen maybe not the
greatest physics demo in the world but
i've got one
so the idea here is that if i pull the
spring right
it's pushing me back in the other
direction against how i pull it
and similarly if i push on it then it's
pushing me
in the other direction it's trying to
get back to that equilibrium point
and the way that it does this obeys at
least to a loose approximation for a lot
of springs
something called hooke's law so if i
draw out
a spring and let's imagine that there's
some
mass sitting at the end of it let's say
that this is
where it wants to be this is the
equilibrium position kind of like how my
spring is sitting here
before it just rolls away
with no forces uh acting on the mass but
if you stretch it out
if i pull it that same mass at the end
this distance what we might call the
displacement
of our mass ends up influencing how much
force
the spring is pulling back on because
intuitively we know
that the spring is pulling back with
some kind of force and what hooke's law
suggests
is that it's a force proportional to
that size of
x and we use k as a proportionality
constant
and negative to emphasize that it's
pointed in the opposite direction
so in this context what we're saying is
if we double
the amount that we're pulling it it's
going to pull us back with twice the
force if we triple it it pulls us back
with three times the force
as with any kind of physical models this
is only true
to an approximation you know if we pull
the spring such that we just distort it
entirely
this certainly won't apply and often
with anything that involves
the simple harmonic motion we're about
to describe it tends to only be true for
small variations and as you get larger
variations
the model would have to change but this
is a pretty good one
and it's very general it comes up in a
lot of different circumstances
now force is mass times acceleration
this is what force is this is what
newton's second law tells us
it says what is your mass i'm telling
you how much you're going to accelerate
acceleration is how much your velocity
changes velocity being how much the
value of x changes
now this is quite interesting because
what it means is that acceleration
which is influencing the displacement
kind of in a second order way via how it
influences velocity
is itself influenced by the value of x
so i'm going to go ahead and ask you a
quiz question here that's basically to
have us think about what velocity and
acceleration
really mean in a context like this so
we'll pull up our quiz again
we are going to go to the final live
question for this lesson
which is a big one but it's largely just
stating what i just did
a mass on a spring is pulled a distance
x
away from an equilibrium point if the
spring obeys hooke's law
the mass will experience a force of f
equals negative k
x x being that displacement for some
constant k
all right keep in mind by newton's
second law f equals m a
where m is the mass and a is the
acceleration okay
if the mass starts out with a
displacement of x naught
and a velocity of v naught which of the
following
most clearly describes the value the
changes of these values
after a small change in time delta t
okay so we're going to
let time play out for a tiny step in
time and it wants us to know
which of these four options uh best
describes
what that change to the x value is going
to look like delta x
and what the change to the velocity
value will look like delta v
so i'll give you a little bit of time
for this one
while you're thinking about that we've
got another question in about
quaternions
not entirely relevant to the lesson but
certainly a very interesting
idea and question so if you're enjoying
this kind of side plot
to the full lecture rotation in 2d
requires one extra number
i so why is it that it requires three
extra numbers i j
k and not just 2 i and j for 3d rotation
is there an equivalent way for rotation
in four dimensions
and how many extra numbers are required
there okay awesome question
so a way to think about this in in
complex numbers or in two dimensions you
only need one degree of freedom to
describe rotation
okay you just need to describe the angle
that you're rotating
and so you might say oh why do we need a
2d number system
in order to describe something that only
has one degree of freedom and the idea
is that it's nice to live in a slightly
bigger space so that we can have a
circle something where you come back on
itself
and then we just constrain all of the
rotating actions to that circle
so the way that complex numbers describe
rotation is entirely based on the
numbers that sit on a circle it's only
one dimension's worth of numbers in some
sense
awesome so for three-dimensional
rotation
it's not just two extra degrees of
freedom you have you actually have three
degrees of freedom to describe
any 3d rotation you might think of it as
saying choose an
axis for your rotation a latitude and
longitude
that you're gonna you know poke a hole
through the entire earth
and then after you choose that latitude
and longitude two degrees of freedom for
your axis
you have another degree of freedom for
how much you rotate so it's a total of
three degrees of freedom
to describe rotation in three dimensions
now again you could say
in principle we should be able to do
this with a three-dimensional space
where somehow you associate the three
degrees of freedom of 3d space
with the three degrees of freedom of
your rotation which you kind of can
with a thing called stereographic
progres stereographic projection
which is entirely what the video i did
about quaternions was about
but in the same way that to describe
rotations it's nice to have a circle
something that lives one dimension
higher
to describe 3d rotations it's nice to
have
a hypersphere basically something that
loops back on itself
but it has three degrees of freedom on
it very weird for us to think about
but that that's sort of the degrees of
freedom argument and then four
dimensions um
rotations would actually have 10 degrees
of freedom there's not a number system
for it but
if you're trying to constrain your
matrices and understand things like that
which again this is if none of this
makes sense to you don't worry
it's not in the spirit of this
particular lecture
or the target audience for it but it's
an interesting topic and if it's what if
it's what you're chatting about on
twitter i'm happy to
chime in on that so yeah thinking about
degrees of freedom
and the fact that it's nice to live one
dimension higher to have
basically have a more interesting
surface than flat euclidean space
okay with that as our uh
changing scenes abruptly from the side
plot of quaternions we return back to
our regular programming
of physics and how it's relevant to
imaginary interest rates
locking in our answers here it looks
like most of you
correctly answered a and what is a
saying here
it's saying that the the change
to x is whatever your velocity was times
a small step in time
which that's what velocity is right it's
saying how many meters per second
uh what is the change in distance per
unit time so you multiply it by the
change in time
and then the only tricky part is knowing
that the velocity changes based on
acceleration times delta t um and
acceleration
in this case uh we can work out based on
the various equations
not sure if you can hear but there's
some sirens in the background
in general whenever i'm recording it's
so annoying when there's background
noise
so one of the nice things about live is
that
i just have no option so background
noise needs to be tolerated
anyway if we want to write a pure
expression for the acceleration what it
looks like
is just rearranging negative k over
m times x okay
now for where we're going with this um
it's going to be a little bit
simpler this is a classic mathematician
thing to do ignore the like real numbers
and just assume that we're working with
whatever units we need to such that k
over m is equal to one right
uh and then what we can say is that the
acceleration is
negative x and the reason i want to do
that
will hopefully become apparent in a
moment now the way i want you to think
about
this spring setup is going to look a
little weird at first
i'm going to have you follow two
different numbers
which is basically the displacement of
our mass sitting up here what is x
but then you also want to know the
velocity so let's say
it's not just up there holding still it
was actually moving a little bit with
some kind of velocity
to the right you need to understand
those two numbers to follow the system
as a whole
and i'm going to package those two
numbers together
um as a single point in two-dimensional
space
so let's say i had some position or some
state i should say
that has you know a small displacement
but then a large velocity
i'm going to think of that as simply
being a point
or maybe i draw an arrow to it thinking
of it as a
point in two-dimensional space with
coordinates
x and v okay all i'm doing is packaging
them together
as a single point and then what we might
write is that the change
to our two coordinates the change to x
v looks like
well the way x changes is based on your
velocity
times a little change in time that's
what velocity is
and the way velocity changes same deal
but with acceleration
but acceleration is negative x for this
system
so it's going to be negative x times
delta t
all right so we have a value that
changes
and in fact the way that it changes is
going to be based on
a little vector perpendicular to itself
which is what happens when you swap the
variables and you make one negative
and let me just talk through this not in
the context of writing them down as two
separate coordinates
but in the context of imaginary numbers
which feels like a very weird thing to
do but just walk through with me
this process because it feels so elegant
once you let it play out
i'm going to package this pair of
numbers
as a single complex number where the
real part is the position of the spring
and the imaginary part is the velocity
again totally crazy thing to do
if that feels weird or you don't
understand it that's fine it's it's not
a natural thing
but if we play this out and we start
walking through the math hopefully it
starts to justify itself
because what i can write is that the
change
to this state this
complex number is actually equal to
negative i times itself times x
plus i times v times delta t
y well let me expand this out
when i take that negative i negative i
times
x is going to be negative x times i
negative i times iv is going to be
negative i
squared times v i squared is negative 1
so that's just going to end up being v
so it's that whole number times our
delta t
what is the saying it says the change to
the real part
is uh it corresponds to v the velocity
which is what we saw up here the change
to the first coordinate
is based on v and the change to the
imaginary part
is based on the negative of the real
part
the change to your velocity the
acceleration what corresponds to force
is based on negative
x so this weird idea of um
hooke's law where the force that the
spring is pulling on
turns out to be in the same against the
direction of displacement and
proportional to displacement
lends itself to a very strange but
natural description
of our system with a complex number and
i could write this even more compactly
by saying let's describe our whole state
with a number z the way that z
changes is equal to negative i
times itself times a small
step in time geometrically what that
looks like
is taking wherever you started
multiplying it by negative i
which rotates at 90 degrees so this is a
90 degree angle
and then taking a little step and then
now you're at a new state
and you rotate that new state by 90
degrees scale it down by delta t
whatever your time step is
and you take another step and you take
another step and you keep doing this
and just like what we saw earlier for
compound interest that was imaginary
what you end up doing is walking around
a circle now this is maybe the worst
attempt at a circle i've ever drawn it
should go out a little bit further
something like that
so ignore my dotted lines there
now let's get check to see if this
intuitively makes sense that that's what
our spring would do
because this vertical axis is the
velocity
right so what we're saying is if you
start off with a high velocity
and a low displacement so your spring
it's your mass is moving fast
but it's not that far away from the
equilibrium point well yeah
x is going to increase because that's
what it means to be moving fast
so the x component the real component
here is getting bigger and bigger
and in the meantime the y component the
velocity is slowing down because the
spring is pulling it back
so our y component is getting smaller
and smaller until we reach a point
where there's no velocity and it's as
far out in the x
component as it can go so we've kind of
swung out and then it's as far as
it can go and then it's going to start
turning around the x component is going
to start decreasing
and the velocity is negative and in
general this is just going to walk
around
a circle in our our complex plane where
the use of a complex plane feels kind of
bizarre here
but maybe intuitively that's not that
crazy a thought that whatever piece of
math is describing the physics of a
spring that goes back and forth
and critically i should specify this as
a spring where we're not taking into
account friction
so it'll just oscillate back and forth
forever that oscillation
corresponds with circular motion and we
can see this maybe even more concretely
if we write out the math of it so what
we just saw is that imaginary compound
interest
invites us to write the solution the
place that we're going to be after an
amount of time t as
wherever we were in the beginning times
e to the power of that interest rate
where in this case the interest rate is
negative i the thing influencing how you
change it's not in the direction
of where you are it's 90 degrees to
where you are times the time
this is actually a reasonable way to
write things and it mirrors how you
might see things written
in certain parts of actual physics this
e to the i t
term shows up anytime you have this kind
of oscillation
and the oscillation often corresponds to
forces that are proportional to the
displacement itself
it all loops together it's all connected
now if you wanted
to make this i don't know connect with
the kind of graphs and functions that
we see elsewhere you could write this
using
euler's formula writing the uh expansion
of the fact that e to an imaginary
constant walks around a circle
as your initial state times
the cosine of t and minus
i times the sine of t
and what this is basically saying is if
we were to independently graph
the displacements and the velocities
they would look like sine waves okay so
i'm just going to draw out
a couple different plots here where on
each one i'm going to
let the x represent time that we're
moving forward
and in one of them we're going to plot
the displacement well let's say the
displacement started off entirely at 1
and the velocity was 0.
what it would look like would just be
this cosine of t
excuse me cosine of t real component
of uh of our weird complex number
description of things but if if that all
feels weird hopefully it feels more
concrete when you realize all that
saying
is that the position of the spring
oscillates back and forth in a nice
little cosine wave
which matches physical intuition it kind
of oscillates back and forth
in this gentle smooth wave and then
similarly the velocity
let's say it started off at zero what
our
euler's formula is telling us
is that this will end up being a
negative sine
wave so it's going to start off at zero
but then it's going to go down
basically because it started off you
know as far as it could be and then it's
going to point in the opposite direction
bringing the mass back towards
equilibrium
and then the velocity will reach some
minimum and then it'll come back up
until the velocity is zero
this is when the spring goes all the way
to the other end
and then the velocity will be positive
for a while and it'll keep oscillating
back and forth like that
and i'm sure i haven't quite lined up
the waves appropriately but the idea
that each one of them
is this sort of sinusoidal pattern and
that they're out of sync with each other
hopefully lines up with some physical
reasoning and i just think it's
beautiful that what you can see is
happening
is it is uh two different shadows of
circular motion
in an abstract mathematical idea of
packaging the
two components as a real and imaginary
part
of some number because this hooke's law
let us describe things at a 90 degree
angle
and all of that is actually deeper than
you might think it is there are certain
formalizations
of classical newtonian mechanics that
introduce complex numbers
for pretty similar reasons to what's
going on here it's all a bit advanced i
won't necessarily go into it
but what i want to emphasize is that
this original question we asked of what
happens if your bank offers you an
imaginary interest rate
isn't totally insane and in fact at
least it's insane for money but it's not
insane as an abstract idea to pursue
and it corresponds to some very real
things so with that
i'm going to go ahead and take one final
question from the audience and then
say my goodbyes so the last question we
have
for today can we get some hints or
thoughts
on the last challenge from the previous
lecture particularly x
x for matrices excellent that was a hard
question
by the way the homework that i left at
the end of last lecture
so remember last lecture we were talking
all about
thinking of the exponential function as
this
infinite polynomial and hopefully today
the fact that it came from our limiting
expression
i didn't show why but it's we could call
that homework number two for today if
you're really ambitious
is showing that this expression that
comes from compound interest
ends up expanding to be this polynomial
which is
what we what we mean anytime we refer to
e to the x in math
at least in modern math so i asked some
questions on the homework that involved
expanding this out
all around trying to understand the the
crucial equation
that when you add two numbers in the
input
this is the same as multiplying two
outputs okay
and then what we have on screen uh is
asking about
uh for matrices uh what goes on here so
the thing that
um again this is kind of advanced and
maybe i feel a little bit bad about that
if i didn't properly emphasize it in
giving the homework
the thing i want you to notice is when
you go through parts one and two of the
homework
where you're expanding it out and
especially in the case of part two where
you're expanding things out
to think critically about whether
um the commutative property
x times y equals y times x is needed or
relevant
okay because often when we expand out
binomial terms
it assumes that this is true and the
reason that the
the math for expanding binomial terms
looks like what it does
um the reason it works has everything to
do with the fact that
order of multiplication doesn't matter
this is particularly relevant
in uh part two where you know we're
expanding
this x of x plus y and when you do that
you're going to run into these terms
that look like x plus y to the power
n and then the uh the parts
of that are going to end up looking like
n choose k uh where this is the
binomial constant so import that's a bit
of prerequisite knowledge if you don't
have the prerequisite knowledge don't
uh don't feel intimidated by these
problems it just means that
there's a little bit more to learn the
only reason that this expansion would
work
is if you have the commutative property
so it's very subtle
but what this means is that the whole
line of argumentation to show this
property
doesn't work if the things that you're
plugging in don't
commute with each other where x times y
is not necessarily y times x
for complex numbers this is true for
real numbers this is true but for
matrices that's actually not true
um and this is one of the reasons by the
way i actually think writing e to the x
for this is a bad convention because you
have this bizarre situation
where when you have matrices and this
does come up there's real math
that's done where you are exponentiating
matrices
the notation inspires you to think oh
i should be able to write this as you
know exponentiating a
times exponentiating b should be
exponentiating a plus b
but this is actually not true this is
not true in the case of matrices
um we talked a little about quaternions
today in the side plot it's not true in
the case of quaternions
so this convention of writing it as e to
the x is incredibly confusing as soon as
you start extending into the realms
where it's most useful where you have
this uh this particularly powerful
polynomial
um and i'm just i don't know i uh i
think that is a
fact worth emphasizing which is maybe
why i wanted to sneak it into the
homework
only later realizing that you know
honestly my intention is to
[Music]
introduce people to the idea just at a
high level that this e to the x function
is more than you think it is
maybe jumping straight to the crazy idea
of matrices and expecting them to
notice the nuance of commutativity being
relevant to
um to the n choose k formula for
binomial expansion like
actually there's kind of a lot of
advanced things that go in there if
we're really dissecting it
so if any